hello everybody
um welcome back after lunch um
i think we got a lot of ground to cover
so we're going to get started i'm
katherine vasey and this is rob spear
and together we're going to
tell you a little bit about how to take
text and turn into data that you can
actually use
all right so with the prevalence and
prominence of natural language
processing
it can be really tempting to try to add
nlp to applications or
other sorts of things that you're
building in fact people have begun to
expect
that they can interact with the computer
in a more natural way whether it be
through better user interfaces
or whether it be through actual natural
language
so there's a problem with that to your
computer
text still looks like this and unless
you're icelandic i bet you really can't
make much sense of that
but you can still make more sense of it
than you can if you're a computer
we can we can figure out a couple of
things here we can see that for example
margaret up there is probably a name it
appears twice we can guess that this
piece of text is possibly about margaret
we can also guess that some of the short
words that appear a lot are probably
words like
the and and other sorts of common words
that we call and
that we call stop words in nlp
so there's a lot of issues that are
holding computers back from actually
understanding text
but luckily there's a lot of different
open source packages and different
workarounds that you can use to be able
to do something right now pretty easily
with text
so when you start working with text
something that you're going to find out
really quickly is that
language is actually quite ambiguous if
you decide that that's a bug and you
decide that that's something you need to
engineer around or build a big
complicated solution for you're going to
get stuck
really quickly the thing to do with
ambiguity and language is to embrace it
because you really can't do anything
about it there's you're always going to
run into text with multiple
interpretations
otherwise no one would sell headlines
bad book headlines and barnes and noble
everyone would play dodgeball and
groucho marx wouldn't have any jokes and
the world and the internet are becoming
increasingly multilingual
and so you need to make solutions that
generalize
easily you need to make solutions that
generalize easily or else you're going
to get stuck
as more and more people begin to use the
web and begin to use applications in
their native language
so usually when people talk about nlp
often they
they either gloss over things or they
talk about really big ideas and there
are big
problems with that and arguments about
that but we're going to focus on things
computers can actually accomplish in a
couple lines of code right now
so what would you actually want to do
with nlp
so one thing you probably want to do a
very common thing that people want to do
is
take out spam comments or trolls or
other sorts of things out of email out
of forums or
comment posts and so this is
classification this is also
figuring out when people send you email
making sure that the email that is
angry is the email you see first or
maybe the email that is awesome
depending on your preferences the email
you see first
and so to make sure it gets answered
more frequently
the other thing you might want to do is
figure out how documents are similar to
each other
is this news post something that is
similar to the news posts you've read
before
it does your organization tend to
receive different types of messages is
this particular message an outlier
that kind of thing another problem is
obviously search
how can people find the information that
they're looking for even when it doesn't
appear exactly like
it exactly like they typed it into the
search box
so we're going to give you a whirl and
tour of common and useful
uh data-driven ways and to work with and
represent text
uh so i'm gonna start showing you some
code examples uh real soon
um and uh so the code is all available
at this github repository i'm gonna
leave that up for just a moment if you
want to try and uh get that on your
laptop now it'll also be up again at the
end of the talk
so i want to show you the simple things
that you can accomplish right now
and the simplest thing we should start
with oh and these examples are all going
to be in python
um there's all you know all kinds of
languages out there they're all great
i'm using python especially because
we've got this wonderful notebook
which will come up in just a moment from
which i can give you code examples
right here and let me increase the font
size okay
so first i'm gonna do is make sure
everything's unicode because there's
pretty much no excuse for not
handling text in unicode these days um
so
if we want python to split up words for
us um what are we
what are we actually asking for words
you might say are things separated by
spaces
and if we ask python to split up words
on spaces and
ask what the what what we get from that
then what we're going to get is well
almost the words but they have
kind of the punctuation glued to them
like this last word is actually spaces
period quotation mark um so that wasn't
quite what we were looking for
um so what if we say words are sequences
of letters that don't include
punctuation
uh that's something that we can define
with a regular expression um
and so if you ask python to find all
those we're doing better
um and you just notice we got tripped up
in one place which is that uh the word
don't turned into don
followed by t and so you can keep
refining this
okay uh wasn't it naive to not include
the apostrophe
uh let's uh say that apostrophe can be
part of an english word
what do we get now and yeah i know we
missed another thing
um and basically the point i'm trying to
make here is that when there's a very
uh basic thing to do in lp you might
want to find somebody who's already done
it because they might have thought of
all of these things already
and there's this wonderful toolkit in
python called nltk
uh for the natural language toolkit and
it contains
a lot of the basic things that you need
for nlp in a very understandable and
even very teachable form it's kind of a
library that's designed for writing an
o'reilly book around
and there is one um
so i can import an ltk and let's ask
nltk to split this up so
we've got this text here we're going to
ask an ltk to split it into sentences
with sent tokenize and then ask it to
split it into words with word tokenize
and what we get looks like this
and this is a kind of particular
definition of words which would more
accurately just be called tokens
where um in addition to words we have
the punctuation as separate
items and uh when there's a contraction
it gets split into
two uh two tokens and this tends to be
this is kind of generally agreed on as
you know the way you want to deal with
english text
and there are some very english specific
assumptions in here if you were working
with text in a different language you
would probably want to
start out with a different text
representation for example if you're
working with a language like chinese or
japanese that doesn't even use spaces
most of the time you would probably want
to use a different first step
another thing you might want to see is
can we deal with suffixes
um in english you can have a root word
that has different suffixes on it
and you often want to treat those as the
same word so
um here nlp is going to help us again in
particular we're going to use nltk's
interface to a resource called wordnet
wordnet is useful for lots of things
it's kind of a computational dictionary
and one thing you can do is look up the
root form of a word
so i'm going to say okay first split the
text into tokens and then
in addition to lowercase in the word uh
look it up in wordnet using
the morphe algorithm for this is an
algorithm for matching words with
various endings
and if you can find it in wordnet give
us that and if you can't just give us
back the original word
and that this is the result we get so
now wondering has turned into wonder and
suffixes has turned into suffix
and this is a very useful thing for
example when
you're making a search index among many
other things
okay so once you've got that data uh
there are a few things you can do right
away
one thing is you can represent your
documents as just a set of word counts
and then you get this
very familiar looking visualization of a
word cloud
and on the one hand this you know it's a
pretty cool layout
on the other hand i feel like this kind
of word cloud um
has you know kind of a waste uh wasted
potential here because
um the position of the words in the word
cloud doesn't actually mean anything
the color doesn't mean anything the
orientation on the screen doesn't mean
anything
um there's there's a lot more data that
we could be showing if we had a
if we had a better representation of
what was going on with these words we
could make something that
actually told you more about your text
and so
you know one thing that i like to work
on is taking this kind of visualization
but making it better and more
informative
um when you have uh
when you have sequences of words these
are called engrams
and we can look up statistics about
those
this is a plot from google engrams which
lets you look up sequences of words
as they appear in google books and you
can plot them over time
so i plotted the terms computational
linguistics
natural language processing and text
processing and compared the frequency of
how often those things occur
over time and we can see a kind of
interesting trend here which is that
uh text processing was the first term to
become popular in the mid 80s but then
you know quickly declined as natural
language processing picked up because
text processing just doesn't sound
ambitious enough anymore
so very often we're going to be
representing documents as
bags of words that we just take the
words in them and turn them into the
number of times that word appears and we
don't even care about the order they
appeared in anymore
so we've pretty much lost everything
about grammar on the other hand if we
had the grammar
it's not entirely sure it's not entirely
clear we'd know what to do with it
so this is a very common representation
uh so
if we take uh we can look at a small
part of a bag of words matrix if we look
at these three
shakespearean tragedies we can compare
the number of times that words such as
woe and betray and revenge and death
happen
um and we'll come back to this
representation but um
keep in mind we're not actually just
comparing five words that this is a
table that would go on
it would probably be hundreds of
thousands of words wide and we'd
probably want to also include
some uh some engrams in it not just
single words
um but that could make the table
ridiculously huge
um how do we decide which engrams are
interesting enough to represent
like if we have a text containing the
phrase vice
president that's an interesting engram
it has a particular meaning
whereas the voice is not such an
interesting diagram
and of the is a particularly
uninteresting diagram how can we
tell how can we tell the system to
make a word count for vice president and
not make a word count for of the
and here there's a statistical test that
we can apply um
so we can make this contingency table
where
we find the probability uh that any
particular two words are going to be the
words vice president
compare that to the probability of
seeing vice followed by some word that
is not president
compare that to the probability of
seeing uh not the word vice
followed by the word president and
finally the probability of seeing not
the word vice and not the word president
and so this is something where you can
apply a statistical measure to find out
is this cell occurring more often than
you would expect given the other cells
and that is something again that nltk
can calculate for us so that brings us
to our second python example
so i'm going to import some sample text
from nltk
and to show you what it looks like when
you run bi-grams on this sample text
here is the ldk bi-grams function on the
beginning of moby dick
and so there are some kind of
interesting diagrams here and some
completely uninteresting diagrams here
such as dash dash having
but if we ask for the collocations that
is the statistically interesting
biograms and ltk will calculate those
for us
and so here are the statistically
interesting bi-grams from moby dick
and this representation is a
representation that's pretty dense in
information to the point where if i show
you the top collocations for any
for any text you can probably guess what
that text actually is
so here one's the bible
anyone recognize this one
so this is jane austen and in particular
sense and sensibility
and this one
this one is money python and the holy
grail all of these are sample texts
built into nltk
so now we've got this information we can
represent
documents as these bags of words what do
we do with them
one thing we very often want to do is
some form of classification
so there are lots of ai problems that
basically
fit into this structure you have some
kind of input and there's labels
there are the things that you want to
describe about that input
from that input you can extract various
features and put those features into a
machine learning algorithm so that it
gives you a classifier
and then you can use that classifier to
take new input that doesn't necessarily
have labels
and put the labels on it and
when you have this kind of process in
nlp in particular there are a couple
things you'll see over and over again
which is that the feature extractor very
likely has bag of words representations
in it somewhere
in fact it may be based entirely on bag
of words representations
and the machine learning algorithm well
there are lots of algorithms that you
could apply
but one that you'll see particularly
often in nlp is the naive bayes
algorithm because it happens to work
very well on data that is structured
like language
so naive bayes classification
so this is applying the idea of bayesian
probability where you've got
a class c that you want to predict given
these features a1 through a n
but you don't know those probabilities
what you know is the probability of
seeing the features a1 through a n given
the class c
but the bayesian rule lets you reverse
that and
then you just need to figure out how it
applies when there are interactions
between features
and the naive bayes assumption is that
there are no interactions between
features every feature is completely
statistically independent of all the
others
and this is blatantly false and it works
pretty well
um naive bayes made a triumphant burst
onto the scene of natural language
processing around 2002 when paul graham
wrote an article called a plan for spam
proposing the first bayesian spam filter
and when that was implemented
suddenly you didn't have to sort out
your own spam email anymore it was just
remarkably effective
so given that let's make a naive phase
classifier so we're going to once again
use nltk we're also going to put it
together
with a python module called scikit-learn
which is for making classifiers
so we've got to import a bunch of things
in particular we're importing a corpus
of movie reviews from nltk
and we're from scikit's learn we're
importing the things that we need
to build a classifier
so let's get our let's get a list of
documents
and these documents represent movie
reviews and let's take a look at one of
them
so this is this is what it looks like in
the movie review corpus they've even
tokenized it for us already
um and so you get all the text and at
the end
you also get a label on it for whether
it's positive or negative
and there's only two thousand movie
reviews here but that makes it a great
size to run
uh right now in the middle of uh giving
a talk um
so we split it into our trading data and
our testing data
and now we're going to say okay let's
make vectors out of all the documents
these are basically bag of words vectors
and tell the vectorizer to
basically take each document and
make a vector out of its count and keep
track of the targets
which are the target labels positive
versus negative and so here we've
initialized our classifier and now we're
going to tell it to train on the
training vectors it's done it's really
that fast
um and so now did it work
and the thing we asked if to find out if
it worked is how well does it do on the
test vectors which we didn't tell it
about
um and here we see the score it got 80
of the movie reviews right
which is really not bad given 2000
inputs um
you might be able to apply another
machine learning algorithm and apply and
improve that by one or two percent
but also take many times longer i really
recommend using naive bayes first
because you get to iterate you get to
find out what the right features are
and get feedback really quickly and then
you can try fancier algorithms
so now what i want to do is find out
what's actually going on here i don't
just want to see a number like what is
going on inside this model
so this is actually the most complicated
code here because i need to peek into
the internal state of this classifier
and i'm asking it what are the features
that make the largest difference in
positive versus negative output
so i'm going to sort by those and i'm
going to show the
most positive ones and the most negative
ones
and so i've defined that function and
let's show most informative features
and this will tell us what makes a good
movie review and what makes a bad movie
review based entirely on bag of words
so a bad movie review is one that
contains words such as
ludicrous or unwatchable or any mention
of steven seagal
um there's another one that i was
curious about uh which is 3000 that
appears here
and you'll find many reviews saying like
wow this should be on mystery science
theater 3000.
especially because these reviews are
from the late 90s um
um and yeah we can go down to see what
are the positive things like you know
outstanding or lush or breathtaking
um and so now we have a way of detecting
uh positive reviews versus negative
reviews and it's kind of specialized for
90s movies but
uh you know we didn't have to give it
very much input at all
and there are people who will you know
you know promote you know they've got
this state-of-the-art
uh sentiment analysis engine and it's
probably doing
it's very often just doing this
so now you know how
[Laughter]
so let's look at a different thing we
want to find out about text
instead of comparing documents to uh
you know a linear scale let's compare
documents to each other so let's bring
back our bag of words representations of
shakespeare
and we want to answer something about
how
how do these documents relate to each
other so one thing we can see here is
that
uh while there is uh no betrayal or you
know
the word betray does not actually happen
in hamlet but there is a whole lot of
revenge compared to the other ones
uh you might say that hamlet is more
different from the other two
than they are from each other and more
obviously all
all three of these are much more similar
to each other than they are to say alice
in wonderland
now before we make before we want to
compute anything based on these numbers
we need to make sure to get these
numbers into some kind of sensible units
because right now these are just the raw
counts and one thing going on here is
that
all the counts for hamlet are going to
be kind of higher because hamlet is
actually a longer play
uh than the other ones um and
the other thing you want to account for
is that some words are really common and
they're going to show up you know
thousands of times in any text some
words are really rare
um you want to correct for that and that
that applies a process called tf idf
normalization
so you want to deal with the fact that
some documents are longer than others
and
tf deals with that that's term frequency
tf deals of that by saying
uh instead of having the count of a word
you start with
the proportion of your document that the
word represents
and then you also want to correct for
the fact that some words appear more
than others
and the way you do that is with idf
which is the inverse document frequency
a number that goes down
as a word appears in more documents in
particular
the idf tells you how much information
you get from the fact that a word
appears in a document
a kind of funny thing you might have
noticed here is that the death column
went entirely to zero
and that's because every single book in
nltk's project
gutenberg corpus contains the word death
in it somewhere so it decided that
conveys no information
death is completely ubiquitous in this
corpus if you want to find taxes you'll
mostly find that in the bible but death
is everywhere
um so as the words get more specific
then the number of bits of information
you get from them goes up and that
contributes more to the tf idf so now
when you've got the tf id of a vector so
you've taken the bag of words vector and
you've transformed it
so when you've got these tfidf vectors
these are things that you can compare to
each other
they're huge multi-dimensional vectors
but the idea here is that if these
represent geometrically vectors that
have a small angle between them
then these are documents that are
similar to each other so the idea is
that you would get
the shakespearean tragedies to be closer
to each other than they are to alice in
wonderland
to make this representation easier to
work with
and also more powerful in fact something
you want to do is called dimensionality
reduction
so we've got these hundreds of thousands
of of uh features
and instead of working with each feature
individually
we want to say okay computer you can
probably find a hundred or so features
that are combinations of these words and
how about you redescribe the documents
in terms of these hundred or so features
uh that gives a simpler representation
that takes up less memory
and also because it's being forced to
generalize
uh it actually uh tends to
be less noisy in the end
so also
yeah yes that is another very good
reason to apply dimensionality reduction
is that
uh when you are training a machine
learning algorithm and you have uh
more features than you have documents
then your machine learning algorithm can
learn pretty much whatever the heck it
wants to
um and if you give it a smaller number
of features then it
has to start behaving um and the i the
hope is that when you
uh put your documents into this vector
space you're also getting something
where terms are in a vector space
where terms that are similar to each
other are things that have similarities
in meaning
and this is an idea that we'll come back
to later
so here's a quick example of applying uh
latent semantic inference
which is basically dimensionality
reduction over text
using a python module called gensim
so we're going to go back to the movie
review corpus
and let's look at one particular movie
review and we're going to find documents
that are similar to it
so this is a bad review of a movie
called virus
this is a disaster movie it's got an
alien invasion a lot of it takes place
on a ship
and we're going to find reviews that are
similar to this one
so
[Laughter]
because it's fun um
you know maybe you maybe you're looking
for hilariously bad movies right now
um so you know like shark yeah sharknado
was really popular
a moment ago for some reason you know um
so uh like so we've made our uh
bag of words out of um every text we
have here
um so we've got a dictionary of 39 000
or so words
um over these 2000 documents and now we
put we transform that with tf idf
and build a latent semantic inference
model out of it
saying that we're going to turn these 39
000 words into
50 topics
and we just have to give this a moment
to think
there we go and so now we've got this
model what can we do with it
well we can use it to measure similarity
between documents so
we make a we make our similarity object
and what we're going to do here is query
it for
similarity to a particular document so
we once again turn our input document
into a bag of words
and run that through the similarity
object and see what we get out
and the rest of the code is once again
going to be boring code for printing
things out
on the screen um including a brief
summary of each document
and so let's look at what are the most
similar documents to that review we put
in
the single most similar document is the
review itself with you know 1.0
similarity
and then you get a bunch of other
reviews
and a lot of these reviews are bad
reviews
of disaster movies which very well may
take place partially on a ship
and we look at the the um the reviews
that come out so we put in
we put in a review for virus and we end
up getting a lot of reviews
of uh speed 2 cruise control and deep
rising
and if you couldn't tell these movies
are all fundamentally similar to each
other you could also just look at the
movie covers
um so the question is is this all there
is to word meaning
because we can ask this uh this
representation we built what does the
word alien mean
and mostly what it knows is that the
word alien is something that appears
near the number three
um and that it possibly has something to
do with sigourney weaver
it doesn't know for example that an
alien is
you know a being from another planet and
that's because nobody stops in the
middle of their review to explain that
because you already know it
and so this is a this is kind of a
problem with training
uh training a model on one set of
documents is that it may there may be
this implicit knowledge that is not
being represented there
and will cause your model to actually
fail when you give it documents that
look even slightly different
and so what i'd like to have is a model
of word meaning
that represents things that are true in
general no matter what your set of
documents is
one thing that can do that is word net
so here we come back to wordnet
and one thing wordnet can give you is
this hierarchy of word meanings
that we have car and truck here and
these are similar meanings because
they are both kinds of automotive which
itself is a kind of wheeled vehicle and
so on
and nltk can can give you access to this
information in wordnet
and this is pretty useful
i find this doesn't quite go far enough
i find this a bit rigid because
you know you might want to know that a
fork is an eating utensil which is a
kind of
article but you might also want to know
that a fork is for eating
that fork and eat have this very strong
connection and that's one that you won't
necessarily find in wordnet
and so i want to represent what are
these things that people know in
background knowledge these
inherent associations between words
so think about it what it takes to
understand the meaning of a single
sentence if you see
a sentence like i bought food at the
grocery store there's a lot of things
that you really need to understand to be
able to understand that you need to know
that if you go to the grocery store
there's food there you can buy it there
you typically don't eat the food in the
grocery store even though there's food
in the grocery store
and that you take money and you exchange
it for goods and services these are all
things that we take for granted when we
interact with each other
but computers don't know these things so
how would we start being able to do this
um we actually began a project many
years ago in the late 90s to start
collecting information about how
computers think about the world that
people know is concept net now
which is a large open source knowledge
repository
and so we can take concepts we know
about the world like buy groceries and
money and connect them together
with different kinds of relations and we
have about 17 million of these
connections
online but to really know what those
words mean
we really need to be able to add more
words and more connections
to be able to understand you know the
context of a given word or the context
of a given fact
and if you take this out to its normal
conclusion you're going to end up with a
whole lot of connections and a really
big graph and this is what concept net
is and it has an online api that you can
use you can also download it yourself
but it's kind of big
and that's at concept.5.media.mit.edu
which will be up on the other things
because there's no way anyone understood
that
but compared to an expert created
resource like word net
this might seem like a big disorganized
mess but see the point is a big
disorganized mess is exactly what
dimensionality reduction needs
to better understand language so when we
did this before
we used documents and terms but now
we're going to use terms
versus terms to sort of understand the
relationships between terms to each
other
and so we end up building the space
where
different points in the space are
different words and things are closer to
each other when they're more related so
you can see different things in here are
close
because they're you know more related
and that brings me to the concept net
example so
this is the last code example and um i'm
going to interact with the consonant api
here except not really i've already done
all the interaction because i have no
idea if i actually have an internet
connection right now
um yeah um
so um i'm going to import the python
modules i need
which is just requests which is for
interacting over http and json this is a
rest api
and there's absolutely nothing
programming language specific about it
so
the idea is that you can just get this
data in your programming language of
choice in your environment of choice
um so we've got this url that you can
send your queries to
uh concept net blah blah blah data 5.2
this is for version 5.2 of concept net
which actually came out a couple days
ago
and uh to get our information we've got
this uh function called concept
netlookup where we just
give it some uri that's defined by the
constant api and it looks something like
this
uh so here c says that we're looking at
the concept
slash en means the concept is in english
because these concepts are going to be
in a lot of different languages
and then you give it the root form of
the word that you're looking for
and i want to say okay find the concept
learn and take all of the edges that are
coming out of it
and show us you know it's going to show
us a sample of all the edges that are
coming out of it there's actually more
than this
uh why did i do that
[Laughter]
yeah okay so if i had remembered to just
open up the output instead of hitting
enter
again then you would so it would be
showing you things like you know
uh teaching causes learning and learning
uh is
at location school and things like that
he doesn't have internet
yeah um and i remember not to do that
for the remaining examples
um and so you know these are facts that
can be useful on their own
and we can also interact with the
dimensionality reduced uh version of
these
where we just find out which things are
most related to which other things so
here i'm going to query for the
associations that tell us
what are the things that are most
related to the concept good and least
related to the concept bad
and so here we get some things here we
get the concept good itself
we get some negation concepts here
saying things that are good are things
that are not worse or not evil
and then you've got things in a ton of
different languages uh including one of
our data sources even included a text
representation of american sign language
which is
perhaps one of the less useful text
representations you'll come across but
it's
in there and so
um and so you've got uh
so you've got all these things in
different languages and that's on one
hand that's really cool
on the other hand you might want to
filter it for just things that are in
english so we get more
things we can understand so the next
version i ask for
is filter for things that are in english
and here are the things we find that are
good um you know
a lot of these are things that inform
our various
sources of knowledge people have
indicated that they like like being
knowledgeable
feeling important having good friends
um people like to talk about themselves
um and we can
um and we can also see the opposite end
of that scale what are the worst things
like being diseased being in danger
losing friends
slow internet connection
[Laughter]
and you know this is not just a linear
scale this is
something you can you can query anything
so instead of looking for good versus
bad let's look for the things that are
most related to travel
and you get things like jet lag and
motion sickness journey and bike and
read a map
and so these are all things that are
represented because concept net now has
this
very generalized understanding of what
words mean um
and it actually gains a lot from the
fact that it's in different languages
because sometimes
these connections between words are
things that um
that go across different languages
so i've shown you a couple of
you know representations that are useful
to use in representing text
but these don't uh
inherently work with each other so i
showed you ways of doing supervised text
classification
and then a different way of finding
similarities between documents in an
unsupervised way and then
instead of training on documents at all
i also showed you ways to find out
in in general the associations between
words
um it would be really nice if there was
one model that could deal with all of
these so that for example
you could start out knowing what words
mean but also add in domain specific
information
uh so that you can find out what words
mean in this particular set of documents
and that's something that catherine and
i started working on
a while ago and we started writing
software for this and that software
turned into our company that's called
luminoso
so uh currently people use our dashboard
interface to be able to do things like
figure out what color
your uh various bottles of shampoo
should be and you know what your things
should taste like and stuff like that
this is all based on like survey
responses yeah things like that just
unstructured text that you get
from whatever your data set is so um
but we really want to do is make a
public version of this so that people
can use it
and also because we took in all this
data online
we figured out one of the best ways to
actually train an ai system up is
by having the ai system learn while
you're doing something that you want to
be doing already regardless of whether
or not it's
make your application smarter or plain
taboo
so we want to get we want to open this
up to more people so if any of you are
interested in taking out a key we'll be
giving away a couple free keep well
we'll be giving away free keys to
anybody who wants it here so if you're
on the talk you can come have one
um in the meantime or if you don't
manage to get us you can email that
address
and uh reach us or just email us in
general um
and so that's it uh thank you guys uh
this is a little bit of some of the
stuff we work on
here's where the code and the slides are
which will also be able to tell you
where to find all these wonderful
packages that you can use to do all
kinds of things
in the meantime we're happy to take
questions about language
about language and computers or about
any of the stuff
so thank you